praval performers moon five among the
latest artists team up with the Grammys
to try to end gender inequality in the
music industry more than 200 managers
labels and artists including Alicia Keys
Lady Gaga Tony Bennett Katy Perry
they're joining the new producer and
engineer inclusion initiative it will
work to increase opportunities for women
in all of these fields the push for
diversity will also include people of
color and the LGBTQ community now this
comes after last year's Grammys remember
this the so mail controversy only six
women were nominated in the major
categories of new artists record album
and song of the Year Alessia Cara was
the only woman who won one of those
awards Tina Chen she's chair of the
Recording Academy Task Force on
diversity and inclusion spoke to us
about the importance of diversity
leading up to Sunday night we want
people to use their artistic judgement
and use who they want to you know they
want to but we want to make sure they're
also looking at a full range of diverse
candidates when they're making that
decision because we know from the
research if we at least make sure that
women get a chance to be seen and heard
we're going to increase the number of
women
she also says hiring female engineers
and producers is critical to creating
diversity across all levels of the
industry and Tina by the way will join
us on today's CBS s morning podcast to
tell us more about this initiative and
how hiring more female engineers
musicians actually improves the music
industry the podcast is available on all
major podcast platforms we happen to
believe that when women are included it
makes a difference well also for the
better and when women help other women
great things happens absolutely we know
you support too